um Bonjour no no a seashell sure
m'appelle Jenny
I joined up else Asha I just need I am
from Toronto
I don't remember out to say I'm from but
I'm from Vancouver Canada which explains
my horror about friendship don't say
like to mother as soon as I graduated
with my bilingual certificate I have not
spoken a word of French I know this one
probably the only one I know to add I
just like wing this one is as salt I
honestly don't remember any of these I
feel like my diplomas from high school
are going to get like river Mona me a
moi
Mona me and what I remember cat but I
don't remember dog a ver ah is it huh
have a [ __ ] he's a pet occur this is so
bad
I only know Tucker that's like grade one
French chapeau fur hat shusui I think
should we pretend that these are pants
and make pants how long can I like pull
up that long I don't think I know how to
spell it though as an English person
like when you're taking French tests you
learn to like cheat a bit
people play sushi pretty to do sailor
the Salle de Bay asked us if there's a
layout by that the answer is always no
the only sentence I remember is you
shouldn't come from PAH which I used a
lot oh my god I don't know is an excuse
my my Jeanette oh my god I don't
remember any of the verbs sorry all
those French classes meant nothing
apparently
he's sorry for my French teachers who
spent that time is it
J AB please I feel like I'm a disgrace
to Canada right now and I'm sorry
such a shame a waste of 12 years of
studying friends like I'm from Quebec
and the thing is like Gemma CJ which in
this again nothing